M it's
God
God anyone that wants to get into the
Old Testament passages about the
crucifixion of Jesus yeah where you
going to go where you going to go with
it let's go to Isaiah 53 okay
cool which verse the whole thing the
whole thing yeah so you already know
Christians believe that this is about
Jesus you you're rejected that this is
about the Messiah that this is a
Messianic passage
yeah and why is
that uh can you read Isaiah
53:10 uh the Lord it was the will of the
Lord to crush him yep uh quote from him
I'm walking around right now I'll pull
it
up it was the will of the Lord to crush
him and he makes his soul an offering
for
Guilt yep here I'll I'll get it up don't
worries let me uh come on camera show
you guys my beautiful chocolate
Face yeah all right let's go cool so
Isaiah 53 would you say that the
Disciples of Christ were learned men of
the Old
Testament learned uh believe they became
learned you know they had to have some
things that were revealed to them after
the fact during so there was a lot of
stuff that they were lost on and
confused on so I wouldn't say completely
well- learned like that did they know
that Jesus's role as the Messiah was to
be
crucified uh after Jesus revealed that
to them yes before that they didn't they
didn't understand that how I'm pretty
sure there's verses in the Bible that
says that they knew the Old Testament I
mean they were Jews they would have had
to known it yeah well so did the
Pharisees they knew the Old Testament
but they didn't understand the Messiah
and still rejected him right so they
didn't have full understanding until
Jesus brought that Revelation sure but
when Jesus told the disciples that he is
the Messiah then
surely the same who were
Jews yeah yeah they they yeah sorry go
ahead you know if they believed he was
the Messiah then they then they knew the
prophecies he would have had to fulfill
in order to be Messiah prophesied right
sure but not to a fool of
extent they wasn't fully they didn't
have a full understanding of the Messiah
and his role like they they didn't they
didn't have the understanding of him
coming uh as a suffering servant they
didn't understand that to its uh
fullness until Jesus had to reveal that
to them which is why you have Luke 24
where is Jesus literally you know
talking to them like this is what I told
y'all about that the Christ should
suffer and on the third day Rise Again
forgiveness for the Forgiveness of sins
and then he it says he open open their
minds to understand the scripture that's
what it took for them to get
it okay so because there's a big problem
here if
you if you look in the New Testament in
Matthew uh 16:21
right or Matthew 16:16 right Matthew's
informed that Jesus will be unived and
then in Matthew 1621 his response is God
forbid it Lord this shall never happen
to you yeah it shows that he was
misunderstanding things and had the Mind
of Men instead of uh the things of God
you know so that what Jesus says he says
that you your your mind is on the things
of men instead of the purposes of God
but wait a
minute throughout the New Testament you
have places where it says so the
scripture could be
fulfilled if Matthew knew that the
scripture needed to be fulfilled when
Jesus told him that he had to be unived
he would have surely known that Isaiah
53 is referencing about him no this
stuff is coming after notice like this
stuff is a is a reflection this is why
it says you know that you know when the
Holy Spirit comes he'll bring to your
remembrance what I taught you and so
you'll see examples of this where in the
reflection of the Gospel the disciples
remember what Jesus taught them and so
they're saying so that the scripture
will be fulfilled this boom this was to
fulfill this scripture boom this is all
coming after Jesus gave them this full
Revelation and open their minds to
understand the
scriptures yeah so I believe that Isaiah
53 is talking about Israel and Jacob
because if you go to uh Isaiah
52 it says uh it's described as
oppressed without cause taken away yet
God promises a brighter in future um ah
had one which Israel will gain prosper
and be redeemed in the sight of all the
nations verses 13 8 to2 and then chapter
54 elaborates the Redemption which
awaits the nation of Israel following
immediately after you know Isaiah 53 the
promise of a reward for God's servant in
return for all its suffering the verses
that I just quoted Isaiah
53:10 and then uh ver chapter 54 ends
with this is the heritage of the
Servants of the Lord can we go Point by
point so so chapter 54 connected to
three ends with this is not though it
say
servants so so let's let's talk like
this is why we got to take go step by
step so uh Isaiah 52 talks about um the
salvation of Israel right talks about
the salvation of
Israel um and how they were taken away
they are uh you know they need saving
and things of this nature that they're
the ones that need to be be redeemed and
they they need saving right but then it
talks about how in in the last three
verses how God's servant will come and
save them from 52 to
53 how the sufferings the Ser the
servant behold my servant shall act
wisely he shall be high and lifted up
and shall be exalted as many were
astonished at you his appearance was so
marred beyond human
semblance right so he was beaten Beyond
beond
recognition uh and his form beyond that
of the children of mankind that matches
perfectly with the whipping and what
took place at Jesus right by the Romans
but so shall he sprinkle many nations
this is the same uh language of altar
sacrifice the sprinkling of the blood in
the
altar um Kings shall shut their mouths
because of him for that which has not
been told them they see and that which
they have not heard they understand the
suffering servant never has to be
redeemed or saved but he's doing the
redeeming and doing the
Saving right okay so talking about the
like the servants for example yes Israel
the nation is called the servant of God
um but there's there's like two that's
mentioned there's the servant of God who
is blind who is sinful who needs
Redemption who needs saving who needs to
be brought out of the prisons and you
have the servant of the Lord who goes in
and saves them who opens their blinded
eyes who is sinless who is perfect and
you know Flawless and he's the one that
brings them out of captivity while
they're the ones that's in captivity you
know what I mean so you got two servants
you got the servant the nation and then
the servant the Messiah who redeems them
and saves
them okay logic do you believe that sin
is a disease a physical
disease um I don't believe it's a
physical disease I think it's a
spiritual disease it can have physical
consequences okay so how do you
reconcile the Hebrew word being used
when it references uh he bore our
disease the Hebrew
word is talking about literal disease
like STDs like things like things of
that nature no necessarily um it's yeah
I can bring you a Hebrew speaker if you
want but sin is called a sickness and
disease
so um with with the understanding of
that we understand that he takes on our
sins and and you know our diseases which
is sin that's what he took on that's
literally what it says that you know in
that context he takes on our iniquities
our sorrows our disease which is sin
which is why he's an offering for that
sin yeah but you just said it's not a
it's not a literal disease now you're
saying it now you're saying it is no no
dude I didn't I didn't say it's not a
literal disease I said it's not a
physical disease sin sin is not a
physical disease it can have physical
consequences but I said it's a spiritual
disease so it's a real disease but it's
just not
physical okay so did Jesus Take on real
disease he took on real disease which is
sin but sin is not a real disease
it is it is a real disease because it's
spiritual that it's spiritual it's a
spiritual disease just because it's
spiritual doesn't mean it's not real
Central right okay so where are you
getting that it's spiritual out of this
text oh well the text he carried our
sorrows he bore our griefs um carried
our iniquities was crushed for our sins
uh took on our diseases all of that is
in context of him bearing our sins and
iniquities and being offered up as a
guilt offering okay so and then in verse
three it says he was despised and
rejected by men a man of pains and
accustomed to illness and as one who has
hidden his face from us despised and we
held him to no account of no account he
said he was acquainted with grief yeah
and as the one from whom men hide their
faces he was despised and we esteemed
him not yeah so so they didn't go ahead
no go they didn't what
they didn't think nothing of him he
wasn't he didn't have a you know he
didn't look special for to be attracted
to or uh you know he
was used to being grieved by the people
um and by the situation and the and the
circumstance of
Israel can you read Luke 4 uh 14 to
yeah Luke
4 14- 15 14- 15 okay I'm glad you quot a
luk remember Isaiah 53 says this man is
rejected by people scorned from you know
despised Etc reject you
know what does Luke say and Jesus and
Jesus returned in the power of the
spirit of to
Galilee uh and a report about him went
out throughout all the surrounding
country and he taught in their
synagogues being glorified by
all glorified by who by all of them that
that heard their report so where was he
despised where is he reject later later
on when he is brought to the court and
they all reject him they all tell tell
him to be crucified and accuse him of
blasphemy you can't quote the beginning
of his story and like ignore what
happened to him towards the end so
Isaiah 53 also says like a lamb he was
led to the slaughter silent right he
didn't defend himself yeah that's not
true though because during his
trial during his trial he talks back to
one of the Roman uh guards to the point
where he gets slapped really what does
he say let's
see
by the way remember you quoted Luke
which is good so we're going to stay in
Luke for a second okay okay no
problem John 18:22 to
23 go ahead and read it I'm listening
all right let me pull it up I trust you
H
baby meanwhile the high priest
questioned Jesus about his disciples and
his teachings I have open I have spoken
openly to the world Jesus replied I
always taught in synagogues or at the
temple where all the Jews come together
I said nothing in secret why question me
so he is he defending himself no he's
not what he's telling him why are you
question me no he was asked a question
before that was he
not uh sure but he's still okay so all
he's doing all he's doing is answering
the question
in a way of which he's defending himself
no so he's like so what do you have
against me he he didn't say no I didn't
do this he didn't fight back against
them he's literally telling them yeah I
did all of these things and you never
did anything to me so where's this
coming from like why are y'all mad at me
now yeah so where where is the where is
the defense where is the I didn't do
this and you and know this ain't true
and going against his accusations
attacking the accusations raised against
him that
doesn't Okay defense doesn't necessarily
have to be in that context like I could
that's what it is no I could I could be
defend like you were defending yourself
earlier by saying um you're taking
you're taking what I said out of context
you were def to Omar when you said to
him you you're taking what I said out of
context so so right here where Jesus
says um I spoke in the synagogues I
spoke loudly I didn't speak in secret um
um I was in front of you then where is
this coming from now that's not him
defending himself he's asking him where'
this come from he's not defending
himself he didn't stand up to any
accusations okay let's continue reading
he says I always taught in synagogues or
at the temple where all the Jews come
together I said nothing in secret why
question me now why question how how's
that a how's that how's that him
defending himself okay let's say I went
to the store and I stole something from
the store every day and the store
manager doesn't say anything and then
the one day out of nowhere he sees me
steal something put it put I put it in
my pocket and he tells me yo Central you
stole I give it back and I respond to
him that's not analgous why are you
asking me to give it back you've been
watching me do this for two years now
that's that's not even analogous what
that's me defending myself no but that's
not analogous to what has going on with
Jesus so Jesus preaches in the
synagogues preaches in public gets
arrested and is getting now questioned
and now he
says I've been doing this why are you
questioning me now exactly he's
defending himself so it's not so notice
how in your analogy you actually stole
something and are now trying to lie and
defend yourself with this Jesus's
context he's not defending himself he's
been doing this this whole time now
they're questioning him and and he's
saying why question me now I've been
doing this this whole time what's the
problem is that a form of Defense no
he's not defending him he's not going
against any accusation as far as you was
going against the accusation of you
stealing when you actually stole
something so let's use another analogy
if I'm speaking at Speaker's Corner
every Sunday and the cops are passing by
they they watch me do it and then one
Sunday they decide to arrest me and I
tell them why are you arresting me every
Sunday you've been watching me do this
that's me defending myself yes so what
accusation are you uh defending yourself
against the accusation of them arresting
me for doing something that arresting is
not an accusation so when they are
arresting is an action that they're
doing are they charging you with
something yes question let's allegedly
say they're charging me for preaching
somewhere I shouldn't be preaching okay
okay so if they're saying you shouldn't
be preaching here you shouldn't be
preaching here okay and your response is
I've been doing this in public I've been
doing this every day why are you
arresting me now for it right that's not
you're you're not going against any
accusation you're not defending yourself
against any charge you're literally
questioning their reasoning on why is it
that now they're choosing to arrest you
for something you've been doing this
whole time when they didn't try to
arrest you before why why is he
questioning questioning their
reasoning because they're inconsistent
okay so he's defending himself no he can
he can challenge their reasoning he's
not defending any charge against
him all right let's continue reading
we're just going to agree to
this
okay he
said why question me ask those who heard
me surely they know what I said is that
not defense those who have heard me
preach they know what I said he's defend
like come on bro and it continues when
Jesus said this one of the officials
nearby slapped him in the face is this
the way you answered to the high priest
he demanded Jesus replies if I said
something wrong testify as to what is
wrong but if I spoke the truth why did
you strike me do you see that he's
defending himself don't he not saying
don't strike me uh uh I didn't do this I
didn't do that come on man he took the
slap he took the slap he took the slap
and then what does he
say he gets slapped and then he says if
I said something wrong testify to what I
did wrong he's defending himself like I
didn't do
nothing he's telling him I didn't do
anything there's there's nothing to
defend there's literally nothing to
defend if he sits there he gets slapped
boom gets slapped if I said something
wrong you're cool but if I uh but if I
didn't say something wrong tell me why'd
you slap me I didn't I I'm there's
that's that's literally a person that's
the mindset of a person who literally
has nothing to defend they know that
they're in the right if he had nothing
to defend okay
cool forget the defending part it the
Isaiah 53 says like a lamb he was to the
slaughter silent clearly Jesus was
silent the whole the whole picture oh my
goodness and that's that's a desperate
argument Central would you it says like
a lamb to like like a lamb with shears
he was let to the slaughter he was
silent yes clearly we see during his
arrest trial and crucifixion Jesus is
not silent the whole picture is is
pointing at the picture of him not
resisting and fighting back that's the
whole picture like a lamb does not fight
against its sheer when it's put on the
altar so Jesus did not fight back he
went willingly that's what the picture
that is depicting okay not that he
literally didn't say anything like like
the lamb is literally just silent the
whole time when it's being dragged up
the hill or whatever and put on the
altar like it doesn't make a noise no
man come on like think bigger look at
the picture that it's painting but
that's your they didn't no no that's
what that's what we get out of the
freaking context man so why did he get
slapped he got slapped because they hate
him it's the Pharisees he didn't get
slapped by a Pharisee he got slapped by
a
guard read it
again uh okay is John is John what John
yeah John one of the officials nearby
slapped him which officials the Roman
official no it's not a Roman official
watch okay it's a Jewish official man
the Romans didn't have anything to do
with this at this point who arrested
them the Romans or or the or the Jews
the Romans on the authority of the Jews
okay oh my goodness no so you have you
have the uh you have the Jews right the
Jews went and arrested him in the middle
of the night had him arrested took him
and had a like tried to have like a
little private Court you know what I'm
saying trying to have a little private
court before people can see so they can
have Jesus on trial
unfairly then after that that's when
they took him to pilate and the Romans
and handed him over that's why
everything is about the Jews first
Gathering him capturing him and handing
him over to the Gentiles
okay did the Jews have police at the
time or official or officers they had
their guards yes sure they're Temple
guards yes they no not just the temple
guards they had these These are people
of of of of notoriety they had their
security they had their soldiers they
had you know they had their their guards
man okay so where are you getting the
fact that it's a Jewish guard that's
slapping him because the it's the Jews
that arrested him sure not the Romans
it's the Jews sure but the this is all
this this is all happening in context in
in the circle of of the Jews okay that's
where this is happening so does pilate
question
him yes later when they hand him over to
the to the Romans okay so again so this
is this didn't happen yet Central right
I'm I'm not saying it did I'm not saying
it happened yet I'm not saying okay so
quit bringing pilot and the Romans into
this it's it's it's solely the Jews
versus Jesus right now at this point is
he being led to the to the slaughter
allegedly yes okay is he
silent uh yes in the sense that he's not
fighting back he's not
resisting bro he's not defending himself
Isaiah 53 says he will be silent he's
not silent he's talking back to what
does that mean silent what do you mean
bro if if I say silence everyone goes
quiet yeah let's just just watch this
bro uh uh what's the verse
here all right here was oppressed and
Afflicted all right he was oppressed and
a and he was afflicted yet he opened not
his mouth like a lamb that is led to the
slaughter and like sheep that before its
shears is silent so he opened not his
mouth look at the depiction that it gave
the depiction that it gives is a sheep
that's being led by its shearers not
resisting getting ready to be sacrificed
getting ready to be killed the lamb
willingly goes with its shearers okay
that's the picture that it's that is
giving you so in the same way Jesus
willingly without resistance was led to
the slaughter did not resist did not
fight back doesn't mean that he doesn't
say a word in this entire encounter it
means that he does not resist his
shearers like a lamb doesn't resist his
that's the picture that is painting man
okay you've got to look past the surface
level okay the Hebrew word used in the
uh Isaiah
537 is Alam it literally means to be
became speechless become mute mute
silent speechless like
that do you agree that uh context
determines how a word is
used sure do you agree do like you you
know what similes and analog are yes
okay so when an analogy is like like a
or as a these are like analogies similes
metaphors so it says here like a lamb is
led to the slaughter and like a sheep is
before its shearers so he did not open
up his mouth you see how it's
metaphorical to the picture of how a
sheep and a lamb is not
resisting going to the slaughter where
are you getting resistance from the the
he was oppressed and Afflicted yet he
opened not his mouth like a lamb that is
led to the slaughter and like a sheep
that before it shares is silent so he
opened not his mouth by oppression and
judgment he was taken
away going over to Jesus with Jesus
who's Jesus we're looking for Jesus of
Nazareth I'm him I'm the one you're
looking for but it doesn't say puts him
under arrest hits him slaps him he goes
willingly in Chains okay then goes up
gets slapped gets spit on gets beat why
did you do this yeah not resisting he's
not fighting back Peter cuts off a man's
ear don't do that puts the ear the ear
back on on the soldier he did not resist
his arrest Central he did not fight back
no you're inserting resistance in there
nowhere does it say resist how am I oh
my gosh dude okay I mean I don't know I
don't know what else doesn't say
resist yeah it gives you the picture of
resistance and non-resistance dude it
doesn't have to say resist to give you
this picture come
on like a lamb that's led to the slaugh
do you think that if any animal knows
that they're about to get killed that
they're going to fight back and they're
going to struggle absolutely they're
gonna kick they're gonna squat
absolutely okay but in this the lamb
does not but he does the New Testament
he does no okay now now you're being
dishonest well I just showed you where
he talks back to the Jews so so to the
point where he gets smacked be be honest
here be honest here so you you mean it
so when Jesus got smack did he smack
back or try to fight back or did he try
to dodge the hit how can he smack back
when he's in
shackles okay you can literally raise
your hands up in shackles and smack back
come on about to turn me into a battle
rapper and clap back come on dude come
on bro no don't come on to me come on C
this is tough
nowhere does it okay so nowhere does it
say resistance you know Jesus resist his
arrest yes he did he's questioning it
he's questioning resistance he's he's
questioning the arrest yes if I get if I
get arrested and I get put in a in a cop
car and I willingly get put in a cop car
while I'm saying why are you arresting
me yes what did I do what did I do
officer am I resisting
arrest Yeah question questioning their
reasoning is not the same as resisting
ARR will I be accused of the
cop again nowhere does it say resisting
but that's exactly what this is talking
about and you're saying you're accusing
Jesus of resisting arrest resisting and
fighting back you literally just said
that he did okay he questioned the
arrest which you're saying no no no he
just you know he he went he just went
I'm saying that according to the New
Testament he questioned why he was being
no problem okay so this goes against
Isaiah 53 no it doesn't go against
Isaiah 53 because again Isaiah 53 is
depicting a resistance a fighting back
but as the lamb is led to the slaughter
the Sheep is silent it goes
willingly okay did he willingly go or
did he ask questions about why he is
going he went willingly but but why
willing asking them what are you doing
why are you arresting me who who are you
who uh uh uh we're looking for Jesus of
Nazareth did Jesus hide or did he go he
went did he Step Up did he step up and
say I know I know uh it's me that you're
looking for yeah he went did Jesus know
that he was about to be arrested that
night um he knew about the Betrayal yeah
so he said he literally said in case
there's any fuzziness on this he
literally said to his disciples wake up
get up now because now the time has come
the enemy has is is now here boom Judas
with with the Jews come to arrest Jesus
he literally knew what was going to
happen to him that night he literally
spoke about it the son of man is going
to be given over is going to be arrested
by the Jews and given over to the
Gentiles he literally said this over and
over so we already know that he knew
what was about to happen now knowing
what was about to happen did Jesus hide
in the in the Garden of Gethsemane or
did he step up and say I'm the one
you're looking
for okay iess we'll agree to disagree
because you're inserting the word
resistance here but no problem okay
going to go down
to we're going to read 35 to
38 and this is good too because this
just another answer to this question on
did Jesus know and did he try to fight
back and what
not uh Luke 22
okay verse 35 to 37 okay
okay that then Jesus asked them when I
sent you without purse bag or sandals
did you lack anything nothing they
answered he said to them but now if you
have a purse take it and also a bag and
if you don't have a sword sell your
cloak and buy one it is written and he
so no that's good enough so Jesus
literally himself says that Isaiah 53 is
about him correct uhhuh and you quoted
Luke earlier Luke 4 we keep going into
Luke and literally we have in Luke
chapter 22 where Jesus expl LLY quotes
Isaiah 53 and says this is about me what
are we arguing about did the disciples
know that it was about him at this point
no not when he told not when he told
them this they didn't understand this
logic they were Jews that F that
followed the Torah they had to they knew
the Torah let let me let the Bible
answer your question go to Luke 24 now
just go to a few chapters later go to
Luke 24 okay so
disciples the disciples are on the road
to a m uh was it what is it EMAs right
sad after Jesus got crucified and you
know this is the third day that it's
happened boom boom boom right skipping
all this let's get straight to it right
so he says uh then he said to
them verse
44 these are my words that I spoke to
you while I was still with you that
everything written about me in the law
of Moses and the prophets and the Psalms
must be fulfilled 45 here's the key
point then he opened their minds to
understand the
scriptures so even though up until this
point Jesus was dropping these little
hints dropping even these little clear
statements the son of man is going to
die and rise again on the third day son
of man is going to die again in the
third they still didn't get it it took
for him when he resurrected to visit
them and open their minds to understand
the scriptures that that's about
him so at this point when he first
initially said it they didn't understand
it at first after the fact they
did
okay so let me find a verse that I'm
looking for one
second wait what is your response to
this man respond to this uh that's okay
so
you the the verse you just quoted uh I
don't believe it's in the Kodak anticus
think I'm being honest with you it's not
there it's later
interpreted acts one 116 C it's it's not
there logic I mean you could laugh but
it's not
there oh Central
mhm yep let's
see yeah that's the the third
column oh
oh here it is here's the translation and
he opened up their understanding that
they might understand the scriptures and
he said to him thus it is written that
the Christ should suffer and on rise on
the third day rise from the dead oh same
here too and you couldn't find that
Central oh what a shame
Central
Central it's not there it's will not
allow you I I care about you way too
much for you to to create a rebuttal
like that that's that no I will not I I
love you too much to let you make to let
you make that as a rebuttal one second
you're okay but you're saying that he
opened their
minds regarding the scriptures yes okay
but you have issues now because the book
of Acts
calls uh who is it P Peter and you're
going away from this right now no no
it's on the same topic look before you
move on to acts can you at least
acknowledge that it took for Jesus to
open their minds about the scriptures
for them to get it for them to
understand according to the Bible yes
but are you telling me that these men
were walking around cluelessly following
this man who was telling them these
things they were they didn't have full
understanding man they did not have full
understanding and so they were yes they
were following Jesus affirming and
whatever you know just going with it you
know what I'm saying questioning it you
know they did not have full
understanding at that point in time it's
not until this it's not until after he
opens their minds on the scriptures that
they understand now and it's not until
the Holy Spirit now comes and G and
brings to remembrance the things that
Jesus said that they they get it it
clicks okay notice how they need the
inspiration of Jesus and the Holy Spirit
in order for them to understand these
scriptures man okay but the Holy Spirit
was already present John says that the
Holy Spirit would guide them into all
truth would right in the future he
wasn't okay so the Holy Spirit was not
guiding people before he wasn't guiding
them yet Jesus was the comforter that
was there he wasn't the Holy Spirit
wasn't in them
yet have the Holy Spirit be before
before the apostles before Jesus the
holy Spirit did come upon certain people
momentarily the Holy Spirit did not
reside and live in the people he did not
reside and live and dwell in those
people it's not it's not until after
Jesus ascends and sends the holy spirit
that now at this particular um era the
age of the church that the Holy Spirit
now dwells and lives in
Believers okay no
worries uh okay back to Isaiah
53 the land of the
living it says he was removed from the
land of the living yeah explain that I
don't I think that's clearcut he was
killed
what he was cut off from the land of the
living if you're not in the land of the
living where are
you yo logic you serious if you're not
in the of the living Central what land
are you in okay aat a Jewish rabbi aat I
don't know how to say his last
name refers specifically to the land of
Israel he says it refers specifically to
the land why does it have wait why are
you limiting it to just a verse be
because we're talking about the verses
we're interpreting the verses of the
verses do are you not obal like
scholarship Christian scholarship
they're they're not my no they're not my
authority Christian scholarship is my
authority the church fathers that say
that this is a Messianic prophecy about
Jesus
dying this about
it so so if I bring you a CHR scholar
that says the land of the living is of
reference to isra church church fathers
bring me a church father that's you just
said Scholars you said you just I said I
said my I'm talking about church fathers
can you show me a church father that
does not uh that does not interpret this
as him dying
okay
do you accept Church fathers by the way
I never asked you that yeah I
do okay I said I take them as a
historical basis so do you uh do you
have a a scripture verse do you have a
verse that backs up in interpretation
that the land of the living is Israel
again I'm not limited to just the you
are limited to the you are limited to
the Bible you're talking about my Bible
oh when you quote the Quran you quote
you quote Yeah because that's your
Scholars so how does that work for you
but not work for me no no no when when
so okay I quote your Scholars right sure
if I if I quoted a Shia scholar to you
on a Quran interpretation would that
count against you would that count as an
authority for you no thank you so you
quoting some rabinal supposed scholar is
not an authority on me just like sheia
authorities are not Authorities on you
okay I'll find you I I'll find you a
Christian scholar how about that I don't
care about a Christian scholar show me a
church father
what okay again you earlier you
said all right I I'll give you a verse
thank you you just got one I heard a
text message no my phone's blowing up
like through
WhatsApp Bible verse Isaiah
3811 all right what does it
say let's read it I said I shall not see
the Lord even the Lord in the land of
the
living I
shall uh I Shall Behold man no more with
the inhabitants of the world watch this
guys my age is departed and is removed
me as a shepherd's tent I have cut off
like a weaver like a weaver my life he
will cut me off with the pinning
sickness from day even toight wil thou
make an end of me I reckon till morning
that as a lion da da so so now let me
let me show you how whoever tried to
right here oh oh watch this I'm about to
show you how the person who just sent to
this verse got you and themselves busted
stop listening to these people look
nobody's texting me about this verse uh
okay okay I believe you verse n verse n
and and writing and a writing of
Hezekiah king of Judah after he had been
sick and had recovered from his
sickness I said in the middles in the
middle of my days I must depart so this
is him reflecting on the days when he
was sick when he thought he was about to
die I must depart I am consigned to the
gates of
sh the grave right the realm of the
Dead I said I shall not see the Lord the
Lord in the land of the living he
literally is talking about how he
thought he was going to die when he was
sick okay so not talking about Israel
the nation this is talking about death
okay so what what is the land of the
what is the land of the living here the
land of the living literally the land of
the living the the place the realm where
people are alive if you're not in the
land of the living where are you Central
okay but it says I shall not see the
Lord in the land of the living right so
where is he going to see him no does he
die in this
passage he's talking about how he
thought he exactly so if so he's not
going to see the Lord in the land of the
living anymore so he's not dead oh my
gosh pay attention Central pay attention
bro I mean you're putting your own
little twist to it hezek is saying I
would see the Lord in the land of the
living all so let's let's walk through
this together okay
look writing of King
Hezekiah after he had been sick and had
recovered from his sickness right so he
just recovered from his sickness watch
this I said in the middle of my
days so in what days is he talking about
the days of his sickness sure you
understand this so far okay so back when
he was sick this is what he used this is
what he was
saying I am
consigned to the gates of sh the realm
of the Dead this is his mindset when
he's sick he's recounting this
okay for the rest of my years I said I
shall not see the
Lord the Lord in the land of the living
I shall look on man no more
among the inhabitants of the
world this is him his mindset when he
was sick he thought he was gonna die
okay but God saved him does that okay so
does that mean that the Lord is
dead honestly answer even the Lord what
promps that question Central Central
what prompts that
question even the Lord in the land of
the living yeah so so is the Lord dead
let me answer this for you no just
answer is the Lord dead I got you I got
you just watch this come on bro listen
trust me I know I'm about to answer you
I promise you about to literally answer
you I'm answer your exact question so
this is not a reference to God's State
God's Condition it's not about God being
dead or alive it's about whether um
Hezekiah will see the Lord in the land
of the living while he's alive
so he won't see him in the land of
living anymore but watch this hold on
let me answer you he is in the land of
the living in the heavens the Earth
beneath the Earth and in the grave in sh
there's no escape from him watch we go
to Psalm 132 but answer the question is
the Lord dead I just answered you I no
you didn't just give me a yes or no no
no oh thank you thank you for saying No
thank you for saying No thank you very
much so watch this I I like that
literally doesn't doesn't do anything it
does because you're saying the land of
the living refers to Jesus being dead
but in this verse the Lord is not
dead so the land of the living is not
referenc to
death are you serious it has nothing to
do with the Lord's condition it has
nothing to do with the Lord's condition
but but you're saying when it comes to
Jesus it has to do with his condition
condition him being because it's talking
about him being cut off from the land of
the living him being cut off from the
land of the living Isaiah 38 talks about
the Lord being from the in the land of
the living the Lord it talks about
Hezekiah not the Lord it talks about
Hezekiah I will not see the Lord in the
land of the living anymore that's what
Hezekiah says okay y go
ahead good Lord all right
look this is uh Psalm 13 139
look verse seven where shall I go from
your
spirit or where where shall I flee from
presence if I Ascend into heaven you are
there if I make my bed in Shale the
realm of the of the Dead you are
there if I take the wings of the morning
and dwell in the uttermost parts of the
sea even your hand shall lead me and
your right hand shall hold me doesn't
matter where he goes he's talking about
his current condition in the land of the
living he won't experience God anymore
the only place he will experience God is
in is in sh not in the land of the
living not in this world will he see man
the land of the living bro being cut off
from the land of the living means you
die okay we go to Isaiah if we continue
look look look if we continue in Isaiah
53 it literally it I I mean uh what is
it verse 12 read verse 12 out of Anguish
his soul shall see and be
satisfied by his knowledge shall the
righteous one my servant make many to be
accounted righteous my good you know
exactly therefore I will divide him a
portion with the many and he shall
divide the spoil with the strong because
he poured out his soul to
death and was numbered with the
transgressors yet he bore the sin of
many and makes intercession for the
transgressors does it say in verse 12
Central that the suffering servant dies
no
no are are you saying that because the
suffering servant dying this is where uh
people will like understand who God is
and you know they'll have righteousness
Etc is that what you saying when he when
he rises again and they see that he has
risen and he comes back and reveals
himself they'll have knowledge of God
that's that's the knowledge of God that
they have yes go to
Isaiah isah 119 that's an escape that's
an escape go to isah 119 and read
everybody we will I I will I promise
Central you know how I am I will I
promise but we didn't finish this okay
verse
12 it
says that I will divort him a portion
with the many and he shall divide the
spoil with the strong because why
because he poured out his soul to
death okay according to this statement
does he
die I'll grant you that he dies sure
I'll I'll Grant it I'll Grant it but
you're I I don't I I don't want to Grant
I need a
concession do one second you're saying
because of his death they will have
knowledge of God that's that's I can't I
can't I can't I'm not satisfied with
that but you're saying I'm not satisfied
but you're saying because of his death
they will have knowledge of God no I'm
not satisfied with this but you just
said that come on bro you give me a yes
and then you give me a no no no no no no
I didn't I'm not answer I didn't answer
what you just said yes
even though I answered it before I
didn't answer I'm not moving on is what
I'm saying bro I'm not moving on yet
because I'm not satisfied I feel like
you you know you didn't answer me
sincerely I don't want you to Grant
anything for sake of argument I want I
don't think Isaiah 53 says that he died
no okay so we're reading verse 12 it
says that he poured out his soul to
death did he pour out his soul to
death yeah according to the B yeah
according to the verse sure so did he
die according to this verse sure sure
sure he dies I need to shut no yes he
dies he dies are you being sincere are
you being sincere the servant dies yes
so you agree you agree just for that
according to Isaiah 53 the servant dies
sure but again the servant isn't Jesus
okay okay now you said the servant all
right okay cool yeah you said the
servant must die in order for people to
have acknowledgement of God that's what
you said what what I said no please
don't misrepresent me bro you literally
said I'm going to tell you Central no
I'm going to tell you what I said I you
asked me dude you asked me was is it by
his death that people come to the the
knowledge of God I said it's by his
resurrection when he rises again and
reveals himself that's when they come to
the knowledge of God that's what I said
Central okay now read Isaiah
11:9 okay Isaiah 119 according to him
the resurrection is when people will
have a knowledgement of God they shall
not hurt or destroy in in all my Holy
Mountain for the Earth shall be full of
the knowledge of the Lord as the waters
cover the sea uh what the world will be
full of what of the knowledge of the
Lord exactly the world will be full of
the knowledge of the Lord why does it
reference to death look look literally
you went to a Messianic verse again that
it's the Messiah that brings the
revelation of God watch this dude does
it reference a death for the acknowled
it doesn't have to dude it doesn't have
to reference a death here if it
references a death later on you get the
full picture that because of the death
and resurrection of the Messiah and his
Revelation he brings knowledge of God to
the world come on Central you know you
know that scripture backs up scripture
sure but says that they will have
acknowledgement of God without anyone
having to atone for it doesn't say it
doesn't say without anything it doesn't
it doesn't negate uh exactly so God is
they will acknowledge me okay and then
we get why in
53 so you're going from all all the way
from 11 actually we get why in 11 you're
pushing full picture you're pushing 40
something
chapters dude we get the full picture we
get the full picture look you went to a
Messianic verse there there shall come
look look listen the there shall come
forth a shoot from the stump this is ver
1 11 vers1 Ladies If you you want to
read Isaiah 11 read verse 3 and 4 go
ahead we're going to read all of it go
ahead there there shall come forth a
chute from the stump of Jesse uh and a
branch from his roots shall bear fruit
so you agree this is talking about the
Messiah right Isaiah 11 sure thank you
so and the spirit of the Lord shall rest
up upon him the what M the spirit of the
Lord Lord what verse Spirit of the Lord
verse two okay continue continue the
spirit of the Lord shall rest upon Him
takes out Muhammad the spirit of wisdom
and understanding the spirit of counsel
and might the spirit of knowledge and
the fear of the
Lord wait why you trying to read that
fast go
back read it a little bit slower for
everybody the acknowledgement and the
what the fear of who of Yahweh
is Jesus Yahweh yeah talking about the
father
bro it says he will Delight in the fear
of the Lord he's going to fear himself
God fears himself the person of the son
had fear of the father had respect and
reverence for the father Central you're
debating a trinitarian you know that so
God the son fears God the Father
absolutely okay he he had reverence for
him respect for him no no it's it
specifically says fear of the Lord he
will Delight in the fear of the Lord my
go do you have fear of your parents no
no he it specifically says he will do
you I know do you have fear do you have
fear of your parents do you have fear of
your parents Central thank you so you
understand that it's not you being
scared of him but it's your respect for
them right reverence hell no growing up
I was scared of of my
pops you
mean this is talking about reverence man
where are you getting reverence from it
literally says he will delay in the fear
of the Lord the spirit the spirit of the
knowledge and the fear of the Lord and
his Delight shall be in the fear of the
Lord talking about reverence man if you
if you don't exactly if you don't
understand this there's nothing I can do
for you there's really nothing I can do
for you yo go bro but as long as but
hold on as long as you acknowledge that
this is about the Messiah it's because
of the Messiah that the knowledge of the
Lord gets spread to the rest of the
world and what is it that causes that in
Isaiah 53 his resurrection and his
knowledge
that the knowledge of God is is
exploited to the rest of the world okay
okay so let's touch back on it one
second one more time you're saying God
the son feared God the
Father a beautiful reverence of him how
is that Co equal
coeternal well when you have co-equal
and co-eternal we're talking about
ontology they're equal in essence in
nature the son willingly takes the form
of a servant and submits to the father
humbles himself to the father and goes
according to the father's Authority does
the father's will things of this nature
so that's in that in that uh context he
has fear and reverence of the father
okay does God the father have fear and
reverence for God the son yes where's
the scripture for that Hebrews chapter 1
ver8 no it doesn't say that okay so if
you're if you're if if you're glorifying
hold on hold on if you're glorifying if
you're glorifying and praising and
calling someone God is that showing that
you have fear and reverence for that
person no if if I glorify my mom I don't
fear her she's an old woman you don't
glorify your mom you do not glorify your
mom you mean I don't glor what you
glorify your mother yes you should
glorify course show show me in the show
me in the Quan where it says you can
glorify your parents okay what
definition of glorifying are you using
glorify that only applies to go show me
in the Quran where parents are glorified
or anyone else other than Allah is
glorified but logic don't run hold on
don't run you're running Isaiah I'm
holding you to your own words one second
Isaiah 11 specifically says that the son
will will Delight in the fear of God can
you show me your verse earlier you
remember earlier you limited me to the
Bible itself now I'm going to limit you
to the Bible show me where I I just
quoted you where the father gives
reverence and glorification to the
son also has a reverence and fear and
fear a reverence of the son fear of
reverence he
doesn't dude you don't show me where the
father fears the son C there's there's
no there's no amount of time Central
seriously like we're wasting our time on
this you're rejecting what fear of the
Lord means to rever you think it's fear
being scared uh and that's nowhere
contextually that's not what the that's
not what it means but you're not
accepting that so it like we're talking
past each other and just going in
circles on this you know what I mean so
can we get back to Isaiah 53 the servant
dying and y y y okay can we get back to
that please here let's make it
simple uh I think we're done with Isaiah
53 I mean we talked about we're not
because you you admitted something huge
you admitted something huge okay but I
never I need to touch on that Jesus okay
that that this is the this is the next
step phase two I guess okay so at first
you were saying that according to Isaiah
53 the servant does not die then we
finally got to an agreement where okay
we understand that the servant does die
but now you're well you're but you're
saying that the servant is not Jesus now
okay boom so who is the servant
according to you Israel okay
so we see that the servant is Israel let
me ask you this is the servant here
being saved or is he saving
Israel the
servant the servant is being saved by
God no oh my goodness Lord here bro
Isaiah 31 unto whom of Unto whom has the
arm of the Lord been
revealed to whom has the arm of the Lord
been revealed to whom to Israel very
good so the arm of the Lord is not
Israel right no the arm of the Lord is a
metaphor it's metaphoric it's to for for
who for God's might for God exactly and
God's yes it's a reference
to no the servant of the the arm of the
Lord is the servant here to whom has the
arm of the Lord been revealed revealed
the AR of the Lord is
the yes read 66 look but when you don't
don't make me go to Exodus cuz cuz you
do not want me to go to Exodus just hold
on a second just hold on a second
because that's a little too deep for
this I promise we can have that
discussion but that's stay here okay
look you're the servant of the Lord when
it says that he Bears the iniquity and
is a guilt offering for my people right
who is the my
people God's
people who's the one
Speaking Isaiah thank you so who's the
people of
Isaiah his people who are they his
disciples the people that would have
been following him it's Israel man it's
Israel okay so if you're saying it's
Israel I agree okay good no watch this
he says that the servant takes on the
sins of my people
Israel who is so the servant is not
Israel the servant is saving Israel
where does it say
that again he says that he's suffering
for the iniquities of my
people my people not for his own
iniquities right what verse okay uh let
me get back to Isaiah 53 go to verse uh
I think it's
eight yes eight by oppression and
judgment is taken away and as for his
generation who consider that he is that
he was cut off of the land of the living
stricken for the transgression of my
people okay so the servant go ahead
sorry no so you're saying that this is
talking about one
individual yes okay you have a problem
because if you go to the end of the
verse the Hebrew word for they were L
always refers to a group of people never
to a single individual and I'll give you
a reference wait what what word are you
talking about what specific uh they were
the word they were always refers to like
what what to tell me tell me exactly
what what am I verse eight yeah it said
where it says what is they
were they
were go to Isaiah 53 in uh verse eight
in Hebrew the very last word where it
says
he okay you'll see it doesn't have a
Strong's number but the word used is
L and it always reference uh refers to a
group of people Psalms 99: 7 is a cross
reference here's Psalm 50 or Psalm 99
the same word L it refers to
them a group of
people okay
this is beautiful yeah I know
beautiful Lord have mercy again um you
agree that uh that context determines
how a word is used right oh the word
look at the look at the word itself let
me let me just let's let's just break
this down watch watch this I'm I'm going
to I'm going to show you I'm I'm just
just watch with watch this um so when uh
when Isaiah says my people we agree that
that's Israel right
yes okay so Israel is already being
saved and you're saying by Israel no I'm
not I'm not never said that okay so the
person who being who's being who's being
stricken on the for the transgression of
Israel the people of Israel it's talking
about logic do you know the contact
between behind uh Isaiah 53 like I do so
wait wait just hold on a
second are you saying that Israel is
redeeming Israel and taking on the sins
of Israel
no okay so it
says that
Israel has transgressions and iniquity
and their transgression and iniquity is
being put on the servant and you're
saying that the servant is Israel right
no no no no no no no no no okay the
servant is Israel as a
collective but before that it's talking
about beautiful
people Isaiah and his people because if
you know the context behind Isaiah 53
you'll know that Isaiah 53 was revealed
to Isaiah during what tell me you just
no no but no this is good I'm GNA go
with you you don't answer questions so
the because your questions are not on
the point it's not direct here what you
mean so you said you said that the
servant is uh representative of Israel
as the collective yes but not the nation
itself yeah the nation itself yes the
nation of Israel like Israel itself as a
whole okay I'mma ask you okay I'mma ask
you this
again when it says that he was cut off
and is stricken for the transgression of
my people who are the my people who is
Isaiah's people Isaiah's people or the
nation of Israel correct yes okay so the
nation of
Israel is having their transgressions
placed upon the servant the nation of
Israel is having their trans
transgressions placed on the servant
okay who is the servant cuz we already
got that the nation of Israel is the
people with transgression who's the
servant okay logic this is why I asked
you do you know the context behind
Isaiah 53 when it was revealed to do
with what we're talking about it does
though yes we know why it's revealed why
it's revealed because these people are
sinners they're in bondage and they're
Sinners they need Redemption yes no not
at all okay so now we're about to go
somewhere else dude just stay this is
why I keep saying it has nothing to do
the it has nothing to do with it Isaiah
53 was revealed when when Isaiah and his
people were surrounded were surrounded
on all four corners were about to lose
under the rule of King ahaz and God oh
my gosh what okay just I this is why I'm
asking you this is why I'm asking you
this question just please just answer
the question in the context but you're
not answering any of my
questions cro this is this is going to
be impossible bro but I asked cont when
was
this is going this is going to be
impossible literally you're literally
has nothing to do what we're talking
about it does what do you mean it
doesn't okay okay okay okay so you're
telling me so is this about any sin
offering at all what do you mean what do
you mean sin offering does this have to
do with a sin
offering no so when it says in verse 10
that his soul was given as a giftt
offering for sin you're still rejecting
that this is about a sin offering
yes you see how this goes
metaphorical when you say it's
metaphorical when when the verse
literally tells you that the servant
soul is given as a sin offering and you
say oh no it's not a sin offering but
when when the same ver tells you that he
will see his offspring it's
noton this hold on logic when the same
verse literally tells you that that
servant will see his offspring it's not
literal
right of course not because we have
evidence of that we have the cont the
double standard look at the dou double
standard what is your what your evidence
that the guilt offering is is
metaphorical what what is yours that
it's literal Isa Isaiah 57 Isaiah Isaiah
57 when it talks about The Offspring we
see evidence that Offspring is me is is
metaphorical and we see that the Messiah
has metaphorical children he literally
calls his disciples his children his
followers his sons and daughters he
literally calls them children the Hebrew
word Zeta what does it mean it means
seed seed did Jesus have seed yes he had
seed
Lal metaphorical seed metaphorical
you're taking half the verse saying it's
literal the other half saying it's
metaphor no I'm not I'm giving I'm
giving evidence for why it's it's
metaphorical and I am okay so give me
okay so show me look notice watch this
just slow down Central notice how I have
an exact verse I have verses to
demonstrate that the word zeras seed is
used metaphorically and that Jesus
himself watch just hold on and that
Jesus himself calls his followers his
children okay so we understand that seed
is can be taken
metaphorically what evidence what's what
scripture do you have that says that a
guilt offering a sin offering is
figurative okay I Okay cool so you're
the one that's arguing that not me but
anyways logic let's just make this easy
do you
agree do you agree that the Jews have an
oral La run away from you're running
away from verse eight man I I already
replied to verse eight what do you mean
no you didn't when I asked you about who
the people of Isaiah are you agree that
that's the na is give you the context of
who Isaiah's people are you didn't want
to go there okay no let's just let's
just let's just grant it all so Isaiah's
people are the nation of Israel right no
my friend no no no no no no no no no no
this is why I asked you do you know
where where why and what this is C was
Isaiah 53 revealed you said talking
about Sin offering I said no it's not oh
yeah well verse 10 literally says it's
wor referring to a sin offering okay but
verse verse verse verse 10 uh verse 11
and 12 literally says that he's an
intercessor for people's sins that he
takes on took on the sins of the people
and is a offering for sins it literally
says this multiple times throughout
Isaiah 53 there's no way around it dude
Isaiah okay it doesn't no no wait you
said intercession in verse 10 in verse
12 in verse 11 12 where does it say
intercession vers
12 he poured out his soul to death for
the
transgressors and bore the sins of many
and for the
transgressors made
intercession what version you reading um
the Hebrew Interlinear you can go to any
English translation any
Hebrew
dog cuz I've been trying to keep up with
you and I've noticed you've been using
different translations that's why I
asked which translation I've only used
I've only used the ESV this whole time I
went to the Hebrew when you told me to
check the Hebrew on that one word that's
the only time I went to the Hebrew
that's a little cat
[Laughter]
but what was the verse you said again
verse 12 at the
end
okay you see it don't you no I'm trying
to find it uh on dude it's verse it's
verse 12 the end of the phone going slow
hold on I gave you time it's not slow
you just read it I I saw your face you
just saw it verse 10 right here Shabbat
org no verse 12 verse 12 okay verse 12
okay interceded okay yeah the word
interceded is there but you okay I'll
Grant it no problem thank you so this
entire thing is about the servant being
an intercessor and offering on behalf of
the people man okay it says therefore I
will allot him a portion in public and
with the strong he shall share
plunder did Jesus share plunder with the
strong oh he he will he will and he will
so he's ruling right now shared us is
going to glorify all of his Saints going
to bring his Saints right back when he
takes over the world establishes the
kingdom of God and the kingdom and all
the plunder will be
ours okay fulfillments here so but but
first hold on cuz I I we need to focus
on the identity of this person double
fulfillment
yes logic you don't understand this
stuff it's it's not my fault look look
look look look so wait so do you so so
part of the verse
is one second so part of the verse is
about his first coming the other part is
about his second coming no it it's
double proportion it's double we are
sharing in this plunder now we have
salvation we have Victory now and when
he comes and brings the kingdom of God
we will have that plunder as well that's
not
true no that's not true because it says
that he shall share his plunder because
he poured out his soul to death exactly
okay so because he did share his plunder
huh because he poured out his soul for
death he will share his plunder with who
did Jesus share his plunder with the
Believers with Believers today we share
in Salvation he gives us an abundance of
Grace and salvation the gifts of God the
Holy Spirit we are plundering we are
winning we are full with riches in the
in the spiritual salvation right now and
then also we will plunder when he brings
his kingdom dude it's it's a double
portion okay now you've been
ask can I ask a question same topic same
topic go ahead I've been trying to get
go ahead go ahead been trying to thank
you let's solidify the identity of the
servant okay so we see here that the
servant right here is an intercessor for
the people a guilt offering for the
people
right okay and is rejected by his own
people correct okay so is Israel
rejecting
Israel no they they rejected God thank
you and his command beautiful very good
so then the person who's being rejected
by Israel cannot be Israel the nation
himself right it could be the people of
Israel so again so the people of Israel
are rejecting Israel no the people of
Israel are rejecting God and His
Commandments thank you so much so here
it says that the people reject him and
despise him yes so our are so we
understand that Israel is not rejecting
Israel so that the servant here cannot
be Israel who's being rejected by Israel
right okay again logic this has to go
back to when why and how and where
Isaiah 53 was revealed because it does
have dual fulfillment and dual uh like
you said because only is about the
Messiah this has nothing to do with any
war or anything like that this has
everything what do you mean it doesn't
yes it does okay so again did the people
did Israel reject Israel did they reject
themselves no okay good so that means
that the servant can't be Israel since
Israel is rejecting him correct
sure okay so now we have just got rid of
this idea that the suffering servant is
Israel the
nation that's out now okay so now let's
continue to pinpoint on who this is go
ahead this is the Messiah specifically
go ahead so look you have the Messiah
who is the Redeemer of Israel the one
who brings knowledge of God to Israel
the one who they reject right the one
who uh uh uh is intercedes for them
right takes on their sin and their guilt
that's the Messiah and his Priestly duty
to Israel for Israel okay agreed okay so
this is about the
Messiah
question did the Jews believe this was a
Messianic prophecy regarding the
Messiah uh some of them yes beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful
now God logic yeah I asked did the Jews
believe that this was Messianic
regarding the Messiah you said yes what
yeah but what what what do what do the
what does the Jews belief have to do
with whether or not this is about the
Messiah what do you mean you you said
some of them believed that this is about
the mess but that's that yeah but that's
not my determining Factor on this being
the Messiah it's not based on Jewish
interpretation okay you wait a minute
hold
on so you're telling me that the Jews
who these books were revealed to they
didn't interpret this law they didn't
have transmission of this law I didn't
say anything like that what I'm saying
is that's what you're saying my my
conclusion is not based off of
interpretation of uh orth and rabic Jews
that's what I'm saying okay neither you
want if you want if you want to get real
technical the real Jews the Christians
the disciples they interpreted Isaiah 53
to be about Jesus as we see okay so show
me anyone in this list from going back
to
Moses all the way down to modern
day that interpreted Isaiah 53 to be
speaking about the Messiah Luke Matthew
Peter Jesus himself Luke is not
mentioned here Peter's not mentioned I
don't care who's I don't care who's
mentioned there that's not my Authority
what bro what is okay if you lived at
the time of Moses would he have been in
authority to you Isaiah 53 is now
revealed in the time of Moses okay
Isaiah is right here would Isaiah been
in authority to you Isaiah yes okay did
Isaiah say this prophecy was about the
Messiah yes or no yeah yes yes he's
talking about the Messiah here in Isaiah
52 and 53 he's talking about the Messiah
so when Isaiah taught the oral law to
Micah and Micah taught it to yel and
taught it to oral law yes the
transmission of the oral law dude dude
dude we're not talking about no oral law
I'm not a rabbi Jew and a rabic Jew is
not my authority can you get back to the
scripture and the text and deal with the
point that we just made bro I'm I'm
asking you which of these people this
has nothing to do with me this has
nothing to do with my point what do you
it has to do with my point I've answered
all your questions but you don't want to
answer mine no no but no you no dude so
look we got to the point where we
understand that it's not the nation of
Israel and why it's the Messiah I want
you to respond to that that based on the
text of Isaiah 53 that it's Messianic
dealing with the priesthood and the
Priestly duties of the Messiah as the
intercessor of Israel who Israel
rejected who they despised and how he
takes on their sins and and and and and
redeems them right okay that's what I'm
that's what we're on can you deal with
that okay it doesn't ref reference Jesus
my friend and I made arguments against
it and you're arguing semantics with me
like okay so what is your argument that
it's not Messianic okay I made the
argument that uh the argument you said
where he was led like a lamb to to the
slaughter and he was quiet I made an
argument against that we already got rid
of that you you got rid of that arguing
semantics though if you want to call it
semantics you can call it want I mean I
made my argument to why it's not about
the Messiah no you didn't what logic
what we we got rid of all of that we
debunked all of that we know it's okay
so let me ask you this since we know
that it's not the nation of Israel who
is it you if you say it's not the
Messiah who is it that Israel rejects
who takes on the sin of Israel who
Israel uh uh despises who uh who came to
Israel as one of their own and they had
him killed cut from the land of the
living where his soul is given up as a
sin offering and as he is an intercessor
who is that if it's not the Messiah cool
so like I said in order to understand
Isaiah 53 you need to understand what
where it was revealed why it was
revealed and when it was revealed which
I try to tell you but you didn't want to
listen I'm listening bro I'm B based on
that answer I should hear the answer of
who this servant is since it's not the
Messiah since it's not we know it's not
Israel you saying it's not the Messiah
so who is it who is it so again isaia 53
was revealed to
Isaiah when they were surrounded on all
four uh corners of the earth about to be
crushed this is why Isaiah 53:1
references the arm of the Lord unto whom
has the arm of the Lord been revealed
it's a reference to Exodus 66 God Saves
the Israelites from the Exile in Exodus
66 and it mentions the right hand of or
the arm of the Lord so the people of
Isaiah were surrounded on all four
Nation or all four sides of the world
they thought they were going to lose and
God Saves them and they still continue
to sin transgress against God and God is
still telling them that yes I'll still
save you even though you did this I'm
asking who is it Central Central who is
it it's Israel I you already said it's
not no you already agreed that it's not
how when did I that it's not
when I said it's Israel I've been saying
it's
Israel okay all right go to Isaiah 49
for me my
God go
ahead Central Central
Central I love you bro I love you too
but after this we gonna talk about
something else
yeah uh
no so Isaiah
49 um starting at verse one listen to me
oh coastlands and give attention you
peoples from
afar the Lord called me from the womb
from the body of my mother he named my
name he made my mouth like a sharp sword
in the shadow of his hand he hid me he
made me a polished
arrow in his quiver he hid me away are
you listening yeah you reading along it
sound like you texting I need you with
I'm actually writing down your
points I didn't write I didn't make a
point yet no I'm writing down Isaiah 49
and what you're referencing if you want
I can show you okay okay now I believe
you just I want you to read along with
me okay I want you to get this I want
you to come to the same conclusion I
have it's not about winning to me and I
know it's not I hope it's not for you
too but look yeah listen to me Po lands
pay attention you people from afar yeah
keep going I'm here okay um
made my mouth like a sharp arrow in the
shadow of his hand he hid me he made me
a a polished Arrow all right in his
quiver he hid me away and he said to me
you are my servant Israel in whom I will
be
glorified so the servant here is named
Israel right uhhuh and this servant
Israel is righteous uh uh you know
speaks God's word and all these kind of
things it's close to God nothing wrong
with right now watch this but then he
says but I said I have labored in
vain yet surely my right is with the
Lord and my recompense with my God so
Israel the servant here the servant
who's identified as Israel is saying
that he labored for nothing that he did
his work and it seems like it was
pointless yet he says that his reward is
still with God and His recompense is
with God right m
verse 5 and now the Lord says to me he
who formed me from the womb to be his
servant to bring Jacob back to him and
that Israel might be gathered to him now
hold on a second we have Israel already
who's being who's speaking who says that
he's been laboring for God and it seems
like it's for nothing and then he says
that the Lord has chosen him to bring
back Israel and to bring back
Jacob so how many israels do you see so
far Jacob is Israel like yep Jacob is
Israel and who's bringing Jacob back
according to Isaiah
49 who's bringing Israel back which
verse are you specifically referring to
verse verse verse five it says and now
the Lord says he who formed me from the
womb to be his servant to bring back
Jacob to him and that Israel might be
gathered to him so who's the one that's
bringing back Jacob to God and bringing
Israel back to God so it have to be
God I agree but specifically it's the
servant though okay right okay do you
agree what
see wait do you like okay do you see how
it's the servant of God that's bringing
back Jacob and bringing back Israel to
God
sure okay so Israel is bringing back
Israel Israel the servant is bringing
back Israel the nation
right
okay so do you see how there is a
distinction here between Israel the
servant the
individual who saves Israel the
nation yeah but verse six uh my servant
to establish the tribes of Jacob and to
bring back the besieged of Israel but I
will make you a light of Nations so that
my salvation shall be until the end of
the Earth mhm so so the servant here the
servant here who saves
Israel is not Israel the nation correct
okay it's an individual who saves Israel
right oh where are you seeing an IND
individual the the person redeeming
Israel would be
God I agree it's God in the flesh but
look verse verse uh three he said to me
you are my servant Israel in whom I will
be glorified but I said I have labored
in vain this is the servant talking back
to God I have labored in vain right uhuh
I have spent my strength for nothing and
vanity yet surely my right is with the
Lord and my recompense with my God so
the
servant of God
is laboring for God doing work for God
and what is his work to bring back Jacob
and Israel back to God and who who
brings back read verse seven the servant
okay read verse seven yeah thus says the
Lord the Redeemer of Israel and His Holy
One to to one deeply despised uphor the
nation uphor by the nation the servant
of rulers Kings shall see and arise
princes shall prostrate themselves
because the Lord who is faithful the
Holy One of Israel who has chosen you
okay so God is faithful so hold on hold
on where did Kings and princes prostrate
the Christ you're skipping the points
bro
what I can't do this with you bro you
bring no I can't do this with you this
is question this is tough and then I ask
one this is tough where in verse seven
it says you we're literally focused on
five and six you skip to seven that it
doesn't even help you with a point it
does not help you with the point but all
it says is that God is faithful to
Israel who raises them up okay who has
chosen them yes so he's being faithful
by saving them right and I said it's the
so how did how did he save them
according to verse five and six I
already said it's God saving them how
did he do it okay good how did he do it
according to verse six how did he do it
okay let's read verse
six but then you don't want to read
verse 7 Subhan Allah we just read verse
7 I have no problem with verse 7 okay it
it's it's irrelevant to the point being
made here I got I got and he said it is
too light for you to be my servant to
establish the tribes of Jacob and to
bring back the besieged of Israel but I
will make you a light of Nations so that
my salvation shall be until the end of
the Earth good so who brings back Jacob
and Israel who brings them back and
saves them God in verse seven he
clarifies that it's God wait wait wait a
second so when it
says and now the Lord says so who's
speaking God thank you okay and now the
Lord says he who formed me from the womb
to be his servant is God the servant no
okay so the servant is speaking about
what God is saying to him right sure
okay so the servant says that this is go
what God said to him to bring back Jacob
to him uhhuh does the does the servant
bring back Jacob to God sure okay and
that Israel might be gathered to him
does the vant gather Israel back to God
okay so you're referencing verse five so
far we're going to work through it just
follow me and now the Lord who formed me
from the womb as a servant to him said
to bring back said to bring Jacob back
to him back to who back to God and
Israel shall be gathered to him to who
God and I will be honored in the eyes of
the Lord and my God was my
strength so who brings back Israel
according to that verse who brings them
back the servant the servant through God
beautiful no problem okay so the servant
brings Israel back to God the servant
does sure the servant okay so the
servant brings Israel the nation back to
God so the servant himself is not the
nation right he's saving the nation
correct okay correct okay yeah thank you
so notice here though that the servant
what is his name in verse
three verse okay let's go to verse three
and he said to me you are my servant
Israel so do you see how the individual
the servant the individual his name is
Israel but he's an individual okay he's
not the nation okay he's Israel the
individual who saves Israel the nation
you see that okay how are you
referencing this to Isaiah uh 53
beautiful because in Isaiah 53 the
nation of Israel is being saved by an
individual okay it's the servant of the
lord it's the servant of the Lord who
saves Israel in Isaiah 53 it's talking
about the salvation and Redemption of
Israel by an individual who intercedes
for them who takes on their sins who
brings them back to God it's done by
that servant can I can I hop in and say
something real
[Music]
quick what I'm saying to you is that
based upon Isaiah 53 based upon what
ROM's writing rombom believes Isaiah 53
is about the Messiah and you're reading
the text written by ROM showing that you
shot yourself in the foot oh my God
logic
a